well perhaps let me undermine my own
credibility here
so
a few weeks ago and i think about a year
ago or so we talked and i had some
experience about and i was worried and
you said kurt don't be worried don't i
had some experience where i thought i
heard a voice it was at a hypnagogic
state so i was just about to fall asleep
when
many people
that shouldn't be a state that i
attribute much credence to but i
remember being afraid because i heard my
wife either say okay or just some
one-syllable word and then i was so
worried and i worked myself up into
anxiety thinking do i have schizophrenia
oh my gosh
there was no other voices since then but
i was extremely anxious
and then you told me don't worry and
even kurt even if there is there's
medication and many people go through
psychosis and or psychotic breaks and so
on
but luckily i didn't luckily there was
nothing wrong with me and your words did
calm me so thank you for that however
and coincidentally
perhaps not but coincidentally a few
weeks ago
i had a strange experience carl and i
wasn't sure if i was going to bring this
up on the podcast for one reason because
i don't want you to think that i'm
someone who's
beset with psychological issues but on
the other side i am driven by a
filmmaking adage which says that the
more personal the pain the more widely
applicable it is and the opposite is
also false the opposite false so if you
try to speak generally you end up
speaking to no one
what happened a couple weeks ago
was i had this
sense and it was so and even to talk
about it now is a bit frightening i had
this sense that i was like oh shoot
solipsism is everything in my head just
that thought and i've because i'm on
this podcast and i've entertained many
ideas it's extremely taxing to do so
because i try to take different people's
points of views
seriously
and perhaps i shouldn't but i feel like
in order to give them a fair shake i
need to embody them in some way shape or
form so if they say well all is mind for
example that's the idealists
i'm trying to imagine what would that be
like and if someone's a materialist well
what does it mean that this was dead and
it somehow emerged that we have
consciousness either way the point of
that is to say i've been feeling like
for almost a year and a half now just in
a void not sure what is true and what's
not true that's fine i can deal with
that except that that led me to
this spiraling of such
it was probably the most terrifying
experience i've ever had in my life
and it took me weeks and i'm still
recovering from it where i felt like
shoot
am i all that exists and then just that
thought alone i'm like i don't want to
believe that that could be the case and
i remember looking at my wife and
thinking is my wife even real how
much of an imbecile and how ungrateful
and how foolish is it and how
that i would even think that i feel bad
that i would even entertain that thought
oh my gosh i'm scared i don't want to go
to the
hospital because i felt like if i was to
truly accept that thought i could i was
on the brink of just losing it into an
insensitive spiral i became extremely
scared of myself and i think that
i'm the type of person i am an anxious
person
and i
am the type of person that tends to
obsess over thoughts
so then i started to obsess over this
and for the past couple weeks i was so
scared so scared of my own mind so
almost like a hypochondriac for mental
disorders where i didn't want to even
look up what's the definition of
schizophrenia or psychosis was because i
was afraid that i would see the signs
everywhere
for example
a few days ago or about a week ago i
remember generally we all speak to
ourselves in our own heads and sometimes
i use the phrase so i don't like that or
i like that i use the word i in my own
internal monologue but sometimes the
word yeah you can do this you can do
this so sometimes you use i and
sometimes they use you
and i imagine we all do that it's
colloquially okay to exchange those two
however then i thought oh shoot
what if i felt distance from my thought
what if the one that's saying you is a
thought speaking to me like a
schizophrenic may hear oh my gosh oh my
gosh i don't want to hear this and i was
so afraid and i felt derealized and
depersonalized when you mentioned
parkinson's earlier that the difference
between the model and then the data it
that didn't strike me as a
symptom of parkinson's the way you were
describing it struck me as a symptom of
derealization
anyway i'm bringing this all up and i
actually feel
good about speaking about it it somehow
feels
curative to even voice these concerns
i
well actually i don't know
i don't i don't know why i'm i'm voicing
this mainly to
mainly okay how about this i just
verbally cascaded incoherently perhaps
what are your thoughts on what i just
said the reason i'm saying this one more
time is that people in the comments
section when they view different
theories of what consciousness is what
reality is that's the theories of
everything channel in a nutshell i see
many of them in a similar place where
they feel lost for example i've heard
that some people who
view yosha box ideas that this all an
illusion or this all simulated
consciousness some people become
suicidal that's actually extremely
terrifying luckily i'm not suicidal
though i'm scared that i could because
i've heard that other people could i'm
not sure if my problem is just
obsessive thoughts
or if it was indicative of something
else and i was so afraid and it's it's
such a scary feeling carl to be afraid
of
one's self to not even be able to sleep
at night because you're afraid of your
own thoughts and what that may lead to
so does any of that make sense and i
know that sounds like it's completely
off field perhaps it's not no
no no i think i i think it follows on um
very gracefully but but you've taken it
right now to um
some of the most important aspects of of
modeling um which we all contend with
which of course is is
um i mean i mentioned before you know
getting
models for our um
our lived worlds but of course the most
important part
when we're a baby of the world is our
body so the first thing we have to do is
to build a model uh of our body and um
work out you know what things that we
are able to move um you know hence motor
babbling and
rattling
um probably more important than that of
course is um exchanges with the mother
um and
developing a sense that
mother is an object and crucially an
object that is separate from me
and that's quite a skillful move and it
takes a lot of my belief updating and
changing your models and building
a coherent um uh explanation for all
your sensations both the polluted touch
or the
physiological interceptic consequences
of being settled for example and being
cared for
um
and i'm taking this route to the key
thing uh which is basically models of
self and selfhood
so
you know if if we are
um coming back to this picture of uh
some um mathematical universe that i've
now tiled with multiple markov blankets
blankets encapsulating or defining lots
of particles um and basically we
inhabit a universe that is constituted
by things like us and in initially you
know mum and dad and brothers and
sisters and then you know
peers at school um that means that our
models of our lived or experienced world
have to have models of other in it which
means you need to be able to
disambiguate
between sensations caused by others and
sensations that you caused as a
fundamental
um
structural aspect of the models you're
going to bring to the table just to live
in a world
which is constituted by creatures like
you
and
that brings with it you know
something quite special um
which
is
a model that encompasses selfhood
so you wouldn't need this if you
lived in a world that did not involve an
exchange with other con specifics
but because we do live your our world is
constituted by other things like us
we need to be able to contextualize and
make the inference i did that or you did
that or it's my turn or it's your turn
or you've got that intentional stance
and you know i've got this intentional
stance
so just having as part of the generative
model of the hypothesis your the
hypothesis that i am me and you and you
is something which characterizes um one
would imagine very high life forms
now we go even higher
to
basically philosophers and people like
you
so if you've got if you have
if you spend your life worrying about um
what is the self does the self even
exist
well precisely yeah well i mean that
that's that that seems to be the the
essence of your existential angst and
all its attendant um intraceptive and
emotional um consequences uh you know do
i exist
and i think really usefully you brought
to
the table the notions of
depersonalization and derealization if
this is for physicists then can you
explain to your audience what those
things are because i think that it would
be really useful for people that do not
know what you really are no to be quite
frank carl i didn't want to look up this
exact definition because i know that i'm
a valedit and i would just obsess over
myself having these issues so i can give
an explanation of my experience and then
perhaps you can delineate what the
psychopathology is okay i'll make an
aside first some people say that what we
need to do is realize that the self is
an illusion you can hear this in the
more eastern end
and i know that many people who watch
this channel also feel like they take
these people seriously like i took them
seriously and i don't know if that's
exactly true
not whether or not the truth of the self
being an illusion is true but whether or
not that is indeed useful for everyone
it may not be it may be at least for me
it was extremely harmful and perhaps
still is and it may be dependent upon
where you are and psychological
development spiritual development and
sometimes these lessons that are told to
us by philosophers or spiritual gurus or
people who seem like spiritual gurus
perhaps they should be taken with such a
grain of salt and i've come to the
conclusion that if it's not life
affirming then perhaps don't follow that
perhaps use that as a clue that that's a
pathological path and don't do anything
that can be drastic don't give up
because i felt like i was in a state
where i could
snap and feel like well this is all a
dream i remember feeling looking at my
arms and feeling like am i even behind
like right now i'm feeling great and
sorry i don't mean i seem like it but
i'm speaking with you i feel safe i love
my wife i've actually whatever i'm
feeling happy right now and i feel like
i would a month ago which is i'm behind
my eyes and this is a person speaking
a week two weeks ago three weeks ago i
was feeling like
all of that could be a model i could
emulate anyone else's head i could be
anyone else this could all be in my head
so
debilitating destabilizing
walking around feeling like is this a
dream constantly checking my fingers
because that's one of the signs you can
check your for lucid dreaming how many
fingers do you have and then also
feeling bad like why the heck am i
thinking this is a dream shoot what if
it is
just
spiraling spiraling tumbling tumbling
thoughts okay that's what i had slash
still have to some degree though not
right now i wouldn't say that i'm over
it because it was such a recent
experience i'm not going to say that
i've solved it i feel like it's tapering
off luckily anyway that's what i had i
would characterize that as derealization
in the sense that i didn't feel like it
was real i don't know if it's
depersonalization because i don't know
the difference between those two nor
dissociative identity disorders so i
don't know though the differences
between those
well you guys it's nice you bring all
those three
phenomenology is very very closely
related but you know
the way it described i thought it was
almost perfect you know this um
either
a derealization um
which people normally described uh
describe as they're looking um they are
sensing um something that doesn't quite
seem real that you know the outside
world seems like it's a movie it's not
it's not it's lost that tangibility
there's no um there's no grip that can
be attained
that reassures you that stuff is
actually out there the other the
converse of course is i'm um i'm no
longer a person um and that could be i
think he'd be even more frightening and
both of these i think speak to um
speak to um this dissociation that comes
with a dissolution of selfhood or at
least once
um
construction of explanations for the
self in a lived world
you used a phrase which um i i think was
was quite uh permanent here which is you
know
one should not pursue this kind of
thinking and self-exploration and
uh introspection unless it is um
affirmatory and and self-affirmatory and
in a sense that's exactly from the sort
of mathematical and dry perspective of
the free energy principle that just is
maximizing model evidence this is
self-evidencing it is you know if you
can affirm
through all the right kind of
interactions be the emotional social
sexual um
intellectual um the the this you've got
the right kind of model of your world
which is constituted by people like your
interviewees and your wife and all your
colleagues and then after affirming that
model simply is securing um evidence for
that good model of your
rich
and uncultured world that just is that's
that that
that sort of um
affirmatory uh process
however
there are dangers
that you um that lurk in the shadows
which you've clearly contended with to
do that properly
to be able to secure the right kind of
evidence that you are
living in a world of positive um
constructive
nourishing
enabling
human beings others other things like
you
you have to be able to communicate to be
able to communicate you actually have to
entertain the idea um that
there is there is self and other um and
simply uh you know to engage in turn
taking you need to have this um this
explicit part of your genitive model
that i am a self
in so doing you will also have um
contextualize as part of your journey
model itself in a number of different
states uh and you need to have remember
before we talk about the good scientists
um having a portfolio of hypotheses
we're generating a new set of hypotheses
so that we can now gather evidence of
these hypotheses so that's part of uh
what you are doing i mean you're you
know in in doing these podcasts you are
on
a journey
of developing different hypotheses about
ways of being
the danger though when it comes to
different ways of
me as a self
existing
is that you can sometimes lose
entertain the null hypothesis that i am
not a self or i do not exist in a
sentient fashion in a in the fashion of
having particular kinds of qualitative
experiences this is a perfectly viable
hypothesis it can be had in a
non-emotional context when you meet
people like philosophers entertain
things like the you know the zombie
hypothesis or brain of that thought
experiments these are all really
interesting interesting
instances of a very high order life form
thinking about well what would it be
like
if i was maybe without me hood if i was
a zombie what would it be like if it
wasn't actually me talking
what would it be like if there was no
reality it was all just me all of these
alternative ways of being
that speak to selfhood or its negation
or its nihilism um now become plausible
hypotheses for which you have to search
for evidence and of course if you are
just doing this in your head and
ruminating and introspecting there's
going to be very little evidence
available to you
to disaffirm
your hypothesis perhaps i'm not me
if you don't actually engage with
somebody else there is no evidence
at hand
for to refute that hypothesis
so on the one hand that is a remarkable
capacity the very fact you can have this
hypothesis in your head i am not me uh
or it is not me having these thoughts it
is not me having these quantitative
experiences
it's quite remarkable it's a very very
high level
ability which which i would imagine
you you and i are the only kinds of um
sentient artifacts in the universe that
can entertain that kind of
counterfactual hypothesis which is
necessary to explore different models
it's necessary indeed to actually just
behave and have plans you have to have
counterfactual hypothesis about the
future and different ways of being
because it comes with um
it comes with a price
if sometimes
you
entertain a hypothesis for which there
is no evidence on hand that could
possibly refute it
and certainly if you adopt a particular
behavioral strategy or engagement with
the world that precludes
soliciting evidence against the
hypothesis that you are say you
so examples of that would be
things like obsessional compulsive
disorder or agrophobia or
your rumination disorders
where you physically um or possibly even
prosocially
prevent yourself from acquiring any
further information that would allow you
to change your mind
and of course once you realize that's a
possibility
you um
you can always or you can also get into
the negatively balanced emotional
aspects of entertaining these hypotheses
so if i've got schizophrenia
that now offers a very plausible
hypothesis for these dissociative
experiences
why am i having these dissociative
experiences well one very plausible
hypothesis i am having i have a
dissociative order or i have a
disorganized thought disorder that
characterizes schizophrenia so this now
becomes a very plausible hypothesis
how would you go secure evidence against
that um well it becomes very difficult
because the whole prop point of having
these
very high order counter factual
hypotheses or models at hand to explain
your experienced world
um is that the
they're very um that they're very
plausible explanations and it's very
difficult um uh if you have got
schizophrenia you're not going to be
able to trust any information anywhere
because they're great illustratory
so it's one of these wonderful and
self-fulfilling hypotheses that are very
difficult to uh to dismantle um and you
see the same phenomenology um in in many
instances
you mentioned behavior therapy before
and um in a way that doesn't have this
quite the same horrible existential
angst that you clearly experienced you
can actually construe
many phobias for example
of the same kind in the sense that if
you are very frightened of spiders
you're very unlikely
to actually go and solicit the evidence
that would
that would confirm the alternate
hypothesis that spiders are not
frightening because you just don't go
near spiders so this is the kind of
hypothesis that maintains itself because
it's undermined the way that you acted
this solicitor evidence for your beliefs
but for you of course you you know um
you know it's not a question of being
frightened of spiders it's a much more
existentially deep and worrisome notion
that in fact you're not you or you're
not even yourself um and you're not even
perceiving reality and these kinds of
hypotheses that come along qualified by
or associated with um plausible
explanations i'm going mad um
um
are very difficult to refute in the body
especially if you if you ruminate on
them um they will go away as soon as you
start re-engaging with with other people
that's what i found to be the case carl
is that the more i talk about it the
more i'm speaking with you than just
speaking with people and not being so in
my head almost instantaneously it starts
to dissipate and also just so you know
there's a danger for the people who
watch this channel that it's seen as a
spiritual triumphant state to be egoless
to have ego death so then just so you
know when i was feeling that i was then
telling myself but am i supposed to have
ego death is this what ego death is like
and now i feel bad am i just not strong
enough as a person which then i feel
like i'm less on the social hierarchy
because i'm just a coward who cannot
deal with
who isn't psychologically strong enough
to deal with potential ego death if that
was even ego death
so that those are there's so many
dangers in this and i didn't realize
this i had this insight was in that
episode or experience that kurt kurt
kurt something was like i was talking to
myself or something was talking to me
and telling me kurt you've been thinking
way too much this is you're extremely
analytical i never would have thought of
myself as someone who's too analytical
before it was clear to me that i was too
analytical and there's nothing wrong
with being analytical there's nothing
wrong with thinking but you've been
thinking a bit too much feel more just
ground yourself here engage in this
world more and and there is also this
feeling that i don't love myself which
is a strange feeling carl that i don't
have that i'm a bit hard on myself and i
would have never said that before i
would have thought i'm not hard enough i
need to study harder i need to prepare
for this podcast hard i need to release
more i need to learn more push push push
push
it was only then that i felt like kurt
that's been dangerous man like just
relax and and don't worry too much it
feel keep talking about this somewhat
publicly is a bit embarrassing because i
do feel like
by saying this like there's still that
part of me that feels like am i saying
this to give my way out because i'm
truly lazy and i want to say this so i
get the sympathy of for example you
maybe the audience to say kurt no no
you're doing great so then i can get i
can feel there's so much self analyzing
that's going on right here carl
anyway i felt like kurt you were
thinking too much just relax perhaps
don't engage as deeply as you have been
with these ideas don't entertain them as
much you maybe you're in a fragile state
right now you can do that later right
now take it back that's what came over
me and also this lesson that i don't
have enough self-love or self-acceptance
last night i looked up i was using a
rubber band for my thoughts like
self-administered aversive conditioning
when you snap yourself if you're
performing a bad habit so i thought
maybe i could do that with my thoughts
so anytime that i feel like that that
would encourage my mind to not feel like
that i looked it up and it said that
works for physical habits but not for
mental habits so stop that